y a lo largo de la historia de la
humanidad han existido las denominadas
edad de piedra edad de bronce y edad de
hierro actualmente vivimos sumergidos en
lo que podríamos llamar la edad del
plástico
queremos consumir mucho muy rápido y muy
barato cada vez existen más evidencias
que todo esto se está convirtiendo en un
problema
yo trabajo en marketing desde hace
aproximadamente 15 años y tengo muy
claro que mi trabajo tiene mucho que ver
con esto
pero también querría deciros que el
marketing como disciplina o como
cualquier otra ciencia no tiene no tiene
intrínsecamente nada malo es decir todo
depende del uso que hagamos de ello
lo que los marketing ya no nos llamamos
el marketing mix es una forma de
englobar todas las estrategias de
marketing bajo cuatro componentes
básicos que son el producto el precio la
distribución y la promoción digamos que
a través de esconder componentes básicos
lo que hacemos es crear todas las
estrategias de marketing de forma
clásica por ejemplo os lo voy a explicar
con cuatro ejemplos simples esto que
veis aquí
esto lo veis aquí son unas zapatillas es
un producto simplemente es eso es un
producto para su fabricación se han
empleado recursos naturales del planeta
se han empleado materias primas
se ha utilizado energía todo esto se ha
transformado y el resultado final ha
sido esto unas zapatillas un producto
nada más
la siguiente de las press de marketing
es el precio
esto que veis aquí
es un paquete de café
en el mercado puede estar supermercado
cualquiera puede estar entre un euro dos
euros cinco o seis diez dependiendo el
tipo de café y dependiendo el lugar en
el que lo compréis está la determinación
del precio de cualquier producto debemos
tener en cuenta los costes de producción
el precio de materias primas el salario
que le pagamos a los trabajadores la
convergencia entre la oferta y la
demanda
y una serie de variables más que digamos
de alguna forma hacen que determinemos
el precio de las cosas
normalmente los consumidores ante los
productos aparentemente similares vale
cuando uno es muy caro y otro es muy
barato normalmente no suele sorprender
porque es más caro este y no solemos
preguntarnos por qué éste es más barato
vale como digamos en el fondo nos
conviene pues no nos lo preguntamos de
la misma forma la tercera
pd el marketing podría ser la forma en
que las empresas comunican a sus
consumidores sus productos para que
puedan ser adquiridos por ellos el otro
día leyendo los artículos me encontré
con una entrevista al filósofo americano
o noam chomsky que decía que en economía
los mercados se basan en consumidores
informados para que tomen decisiones
racionales pero en marketing al
contrario lo que hacemos es crear
consumidores desinformados para que
tomen decisiones emocionales no
racionales esto me hizo pensar
y la cuarta p es la distribución la
forma en que los productos llegan a los
consumidores es decir el punto de venta
en el que lo adquirimos o el proceso que
viene desde que el producto se fabrica
hasta que llega digamos al punto de
venta o al hogar del consumidor esto que
veis aquí es una simple naranja yo la he
querido un comercio local que ha
adquirido en una tienda de barrio de mi
ciudad
pero para llegar hasta aquí esta naranja
ha recorrido aproximadamente 10.000 km
diez mil kilómetros a lo largo de más o
menos cuatro meses
el marketing como tal a través de sus
cuatro pesos se crean todas las
estrategias de marketing pero a mí me
gustaría desde desde una perspectiva
diferente aportará una visión de lo que
sería el marketing desde la perspectiva
de la sustentabilidad global es decir
aquella estrategia de marketing que
consiguiese que además de las 4p
clásicas que se utilizan consiguiese
agregarle las tres pes
que sustentan los pilares de la
sustentabilidad global que serían el
medio ambiente el planeta la equidad
social people y el bienestar económico
profit conseguiríamos de esa forma crear
estrategias de marketing que de alguna
forma tuviesen componentes de
sustentabilidad global os lo sigo
contando con ejemplos
estas mismas zapatillas que os mostraba
antes son simplemente un producto pero
para la construcción de estas zapatillas
para la fabricación de las mismas se han
utilizado botellas recicladas de
plástico es decir no se han consumido
los recursos del planeta sino que se han
utilizado para la concepción del
poliéster de su de su tejido botellas
recicladas de plástico para crear el
poliéster a través de las botellas de
plástico también se utilizan procesos
químicos pero estos son más o menos la
mitad de lo que se utilizan cuando los
tenemos del petróleo
además consumen menos agua y se utiliza
menos energía para su fabricación esto
no las hace mejores ni peores
simplemente las hace diferentes y las
hace un producto que de alguna forma
contempla o agrega componentes de
sostenibilidad hacia el planeta
este café que os enseñaba en el mercado
tiene un precio un poquito más elevado
que el café normal digamos digamos
normal un café cualquiera
porque es un café que
asegura una relación comercial justa
entre el productor y el consumidor y
encima siendo un café que viene en
cápsulas de plástico son cápsulas
biodegradables es decir no generan un
desecho que el planeta tendrá que
gestionar vale
en una estrategia de marketing en la que
meditamos comprender y sostenibilidad
creo que es la perspectiva del marketing
se podrían hacer campañas para
consumidores que estuviesen informados
para que tomasen decisiones un poco más
razonables a la hora de consumir es
decir cada uno de nosotros podríamos
digamos a través de la publicidad de una
publicidad que nos consciencia se más
tomas decisiones más racionales al va a
consumir vale y en el tema de
distribución yo a veces me pregunto
simplemente me pregunto si es necesario
que una naranja venga a diez mil
kilómetros cuando a lo mejor la podemos
tener aquí a la vuelta de la esquina
vale es necesario realmente estamos
consumiendo productos cuando compramos
cualquier otro producto sabemos de dónde
viene sabemos donde tributa ese producto
tenemos la menor idea y en el fondo nos
importa vale simplemente para concluir
me gustaría deciros
que todo esto en el fondo están nuestras
manos porque somos nosotros los
consumidores los clientes y en
definitiva las personas las que podemos
hacer que las cosas sean de una forma de
otra
yo posiblemente siga trazando
estrategias o creando campañas de
marketing para consumidores
desinformados o para consumidores poco
racionales o para consumidores
emocionales porque el mercado así lo va
a seguir demandando pero una cosa tenga
claro que cuando yo creé una campaña de
este tipo o cuando yo sea consumidor o
cuando me toque jugar en el papel de
consumidor tengo claro que me gustaría
digamos apostar por un producto que
consumiese la menor cantidad de recursos
posibles del planeta
que los precios de las cosas
remunera sen a cada uno de los elementos
de la cadena en su justa medida
que cuando hagamos campañas de
publicidad o de promoción de las cosas
éstas sirvan para informar al consumidor
a tomar decisiones relativamente
razonables aunque sea desde el punto de
vista emocional
y que cuando tenga que adquirir un
producto éste no tenga que
innecesariamente venir
de miles de kilómetros si lo puedo
comprar a la vuelta de la esquina
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]